folks joe derosa from the taste buds pod
here your favorite taste buddy let's be
honest anyway i got a bunch of shows
coming up across the country starting in
july
in san francisco
uh
i gotta take it again
folks this is joe derose here from the
taste buds pod
your favorite taste buddy let's be
honest anyway i got a bunch of shows
coming up starting in july starting in
fairfield connecticut then i'm on to san
francisco then on to los angeles
california in august i'll be in atlantic
city new jersey uh september i'm going
out to san diego uh i gotta run through
michigan in november i believe uh and
then some other stuff sprinkled in
between there anyway go to
joederosainfo.com
for all information on shows and tickets
you can buy them right there through the
site also joey roses my sandwich shop
and social club and bar in the lower
east side of new york city open six days
a week tuesday through sunday hit
joeyrosesnyc.com
for details
what's up taste buddies i have six
cities in july starting july 15th we're
doing vegas phoenix and boulder colorado
15 16 17. and then 20 21 and 22 we're in
portland seattle and vancouver uh my
first time in vegas i'll be at the new
virgin hotel that's going to be exciting
they're all on sale right now and that
will be it until october a bunch of new
dates for october through december
they're all on the website as well right
now but i'm finally hitting canada a
bunch richmond virginia hershey pa
knoxville atlanta birmingham
jacksonville tampa orlando sacramento
san jose and santa rosa all those to
close out the year all on sale right now
at savolcanocomedy.com
i hope to see you guys
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two foods gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man folks welcome to
t-a-s-t-e birds chef volcano joe derosa
good to see you buddy good to see you uh
we want to get something out of the way
here real quick guys if you like the
podcast and you want to help the podcast
in a way that is simple and free and
fast you could please rate us uh on
itunes you could follow us on spotify or
you could subscribe to the no presh
channel on youtube
click that like button click the like
button as well all those things help us
and it's if you're a fan and you don't
do them we'll say hey guys we don't
really ask but we want to start asking
now because it does make a difference so
thank you for that of course merch is up
online you can go to either of our
websites to get the merch
uh yeah joe derosa info.com or
savilecanoncomedy.com
uh yeah and that's that's that's pretty
much what we we like to ask right
anything else i'm forgetting
i would like more gifts sent to us
sen guys another way you could help us
and this one is monetary send gifts uh
do we have a p.o box yet i don't know i
don't think so we gotta ask anyway
that's a joke don't i'm not asking we
don't need you to send gifts anyway but
we do need you to like subscribe share
all that jazz if you've been listening
to us for
six weeks six months or since day one
uh
do that practice for us and let's let's
let's grow
together uh today's episode we are
battling fruit we haven't battled fruit
in a long time you came in the house
today and you said do you have any
carrots or vegetables or fruit because
my blood sugar felt i was dropping and i
gave you um and you gave me some
strawberry strawberries and then
beautiful orange that i enjoyed very
much good and i had a peach and the
strawberries were wonderful let me tell
you something if you haven't had a
saturn actually i don't want to say it
because i don't want people to go take
it at the market i want to just said it
i want them all for me you already said
it a saturn peach
i discovered within the last year
and peach is my favorite fruit and the
saturn peach became my favorite peach it
is
when it's ripe it is bursting
with it's it's like country flavor would
you say country flavor it's bursting
with it
the juices explode out of the thing i
need to do it like a double paper towel
okay it's so delectable and scrumptious
and juicy the peach is my number one
fruit yeah we couldn't do peach because
yeah we both love peach peach is my
number one fruit but
i like i prefer a yellow flesh peach
versus a white flesh peach because a
white flesh peach though delicious is a
little too sweet without the tart i like
the balance of the tart and the sweet a
nice mackinaw maybe a georgia peach
uh i mean the episode of seinfeld where
he's eating the mackinaw peach yeah it's
like i mean i've never wanted so that's
how i feel about a saturn peach but the
way he describes it right the mango and
that peach
yeah it's unbelievable anyway my point
is if you haven't tried it try it
everyone knows though i i i actually
like peaches today now i accidentally
battled apple pie with
peach pie when i meant peach cobbler in
like episode three and i got my ass
handed to me because peach pie isn't
really a thing
it's just not plastic i shouldn't want
cherry or blueberry pie or pecan but my
point is you ate a strawberry still lost
maybe cherry had a chance tough i love
cherry but apples you know but my point
is i i told you that i don't really like
strawberries they are a little bit too
tart for me and if i have them at old
i like to have me the chocolate dipped
or with some whipped cream or something
to cut through that yeah something to
take away any nutritional value of the
fruit itself it's too much if i just put
some cheese on it if i eat a strawberry
alone i literally have to like go like
like uh i love my response was that's
crazy strawberries are i mean my god
strawberries are wonderful
uh
i like a strawberry shortcake sal said
let's battle strawberries i mean a
strawberry cheesecake don't get me
started sal said let's battle
strawberries i said against what he said
i'll take bananas i said actually it's a
very fair
fight
as i get my as i get my peanut butter
banana smoothie that looks very good i
mean you get a milkshake while you're at
it this is peanut butter banana protein
powder powder almond milk what's bad
with that
it's organic peanut butter banana
protein powder and almond milk you're
going to [ __ ] on me there's no extra
added sugar okay
the uh there's more sugar in your
goddamn
plate of of of oranges fresh fruit buddy
it's vitamins what do you think this is
all right
i just i'm breaking balls you know oh
oh can i break balls i don't know if you
can sorry i thought it was a popular ari
does it
oh how dare you how dare you gonna throw
that in my face don't you throw that in
my face right well he was breaking balls
he wasn't breaking balls
he was speeding [ __ ] drag
anyway listen i think a banana i i
really i
like a banana i like a banana i like a
banana too bananas are
here's why i think they were a fair
battle with strawberries i think bananas
are a staple fruit i think they are a
lifestyle fruit
i think albeit strawberries are a
seasonal fruit i think the uh thrill and
enjoyment and fanaticism around the
strawberry can can carry it to the to
the place of a year-round lifestyle
fruit
um i think anything a strawberry do can
do a banana can do better i also
hold on let's go i also think that when
you're creating fruit combos
few fruits go better together
than banana and strawberry that's true
you combine banana and strawberry in a
bowl but banana goes with a lot of
different fruits strawberry does not
that's
i all right let me get you go get a
juice at the store you can get orange
buttons orange banana juice at the store
you can get okay who would what psycho
gets orange banana juice orange banana
juice by tropical like it's a thing it's
not even i'm not even making that up
orange banana is delicious i used to
drink it growing up that's disgusting
okay so orange is your banana orange you
go with strawberry i've seen i'm sorry
but i can go with strawberry but now
they can go with blueberry
easily i've seen it i put it on pancakes
strawberries
cereal strawberry banana goes with
peanut butter banana can go with a
banana cream pie come on bro come on
straw banana can be dipped in chocolate
just like a strawberry banana can be
frozen like in uh
we're talking about fruits that can grow
strawberry goes with every other berry
strawberry goes beautifully with you're
nuts you're wrong strawberry goes
beautifully with grapes
strawberry goes beautifully yeah
you can't say strawberry and grapes go
together they do
strawberry strawberry with mango
now you're just naming another fruit and
with sugar
together not a thing look at tropical
fruits it's not a thing yes it is orange
banana is a thing orange
banana blueberry is a thing banana
peanut butter is the thing strawberry
blueberry is a thing
banana blueberry is not a thing it is
stop it it is stop it a banana also goes
with nuts bro
should
what banana goes with walnuts bananas
we're not talking about nuts but
all the uses of banana you could put
banana on top of pancakes
and let's battle let's go let's go bro
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you no matter
what i love you and you know what i'll
double up it's time to get salty it's
time to get something to get salty
your haircut's too short
[Music]
bring it on oh my god it's a fresh cut
it'll grow in bring it on big mouth yeah
it's time to get salty it's not gonna be
it's time to get salty you like to blame
covid on you staying in bed for five
days you didn't have coleman
you you tried to go so far to tell us
that the rapid pc
the pci test doesn't pick up colvin you
know you wanted to bury yourself in your
room for five days and escape society
and you try to blame it on rapid tests
and omicron get the [ __ ] out all right
fair enough here we go it's time to
b-a-t-t-l-e-bush
go on with your banana rant banana
trivia here we go
can we make it a little bigger font uh
pimp
okay here we go let's fun stuff about
banana trivia no fun
three medium bananas weigh approximately
one pound roughly 96 of american
households purchase bananas at least
once a month
like that's definitely more than
strawberries i got news for you good
news for you at least one
what was the statistic
at least one out of every three
what was the
oh 96 percent of bana
purchasing uh 96 and 96 percent of
american households purchase bananas at
least once per month i agree with that
96 of american houses also throw those
bananas directly in the trash three days
later when the things turn pitch black a
cluster of bananas is co now actually
let's get into that too a cluster of
bananas called a hand which i don't know
if i knew that disgusting consists of
ten to twenty individual bananas also
known as fingers i knew that
in fact the word banana comes from banan
the arabic word for finger that's all
very upset that's your native tongue i
know there is no banana in here finger
and hand i don't like that all right
you know i'm gonna give you a middle
banana all right uh there is no such
thing as a banana tree bananas are
actually massive herbs related to palms
lilies and orchids
all right bananas are the largest plants
on earth without a woody stem
the trunk is comprised of sheaths of
overlapping leaves wrapped tightly
around each other they reached a full
height of up to 30 feet during their
first year of growth a single banana
leak can grow up to 12 feet in length
bananas are grown and harvested
year-round they grow from a bulb not a
seed they're a perennial crop each bulb
sprouts new shoots every year in india
flowers from the banana tree are
considered sacred
bananas were first introduced to the
western world when alexander the great
discovered them during his conquest of
india in 327 before christ all right
bananas were first brought to the united
states in 1876
wow that is not that long ago now
that i mean like that's crazy like
you've argued cereals that were yeah i
know this is crazy for the philadelphia
centennial exhibition the exotic fruits
are wrapped in foil and sold for 10
cents a piece there are more than 400
varieties of bananas in existence nice
little
see how expensive they were that was a
10.70
by today's standard yeah go get let's
here's here's uh strawberry facts now
average strawberry kids about that
strawberry flower averages five to seven
petals
technically berries have seeds on the
inside they don't come from a single
ovary so strawberries are really in a
group all their own so we're dealing
with two fruits that are in their own
group
strawberries are first or the first
fruit to ripen in spring that's another
beautiful thing about strawberry spring
has arrived it's such a great you walk
into the supermarket you see the
strawberries for the first time you're
like here we go baby let me tell you
what it feels like shelf life though
let's talk shelf life for a minute
we're not there banana has a shelf life
unlike any other fruit
the strawberry the strawberry
turns faster than any other fruit
absolutely
the story of the strawberry
in november
you can take a banana throw it in the
fridge and have a banana for two three
weeks a strawberry is gonna turn on you
first of all you're not supposed to keep
them in the fridge first of all you can
second of all there is a seinfeld joke
about how fast bananas turn that's true
not if you don't and and that's going to
put on a brown background you know
ripening snowfall has tackled fruit on
more than than i mean they're they've
that fruit is a common subject inside
why do we even buy bananas they're good
for like one day they throw them around
they're not huge you get a banana and
it's green it's not ripe yet by the way
good luck getting into the supermarket
and finding ripe right properly ripe
bananas nine times out of ten they're
over ripe or they're way under ripe it
is so hard to find right nobody buys
bananas on the day they need bananas i
want them for that week i don't feel
like waiting a week what about the
plantain
i could give a [ __ ] about the plantation
it's in the banana family good for you
it's the whole food i continue with my
stats sure 94 of american [ __ ]
consume berries according to the usda
americans eat 3.4 pounds of fresh
strawberries a year that's nothing
compared to the bananas each american
uh that's a lot of strawberries
americans also eat another 1.8 pounds of
frozen strawberries a year i mean you
want to talk about the king of frozen
fruits nothing beats strawberry nothing
beats you're making smoothies in the
morning whatever it is banana goes in
every single you got a strawberry banana
smoothie you idiot i'll throw my
smoothie across the room you put a
banana inside i don't want to drink
bananas tell me what besides popping
strawberries in your mouth and lying
that they go great with grapes and
mangoes tell me what a strawberry is
good they are the cornerstone fruit
topping on their cornerstone of any
fruit salad i ever made valentine's day
you dip them in chocolate what else you
got
there's no strawberry king of chocolate
dipped fruits bananas can dip in
chocolate easily they're the king next
to cherry on a stick dipped in chocolate
delicious chocolate banana is a bell do
you eat a chocolate banana chocolate and
banana is a thing pimp please
strawberries and banana i'll give you
chocolate
i'll give you peanut butter i'm gonna
give you a hit for pancakes and bananas
cereal and bananas
strawberries pancakes whipped creams and
strawberries strawberry cheesecake
banana cream strawberry strawberry
rhubarb pie i mean what are we talking
about rhubarb is doing the heavy lift in
that bath there's no strawberry part
there's a rhubarb pie alone strawberry
pie i've never heard someone say i'll
have a strawberry
of strawberry pie bet me money right now
i don't believe there is set me money oh
look at that not common strawberry pie
well it doesn't matter it's a thing
but
you act like everybody's serving banana
cream pie every day in a week
here's the thing here's the thing both
of these fruits go great with ice cream
both of them
you're gonna you're you're gonna miss
that no i agree can i pl i want to
finish reading my oh look stacks yeah
even man
chocolate covered bananas are even
mass-produced i want the audience to
take note that i let you read your stats
can i read my stats
for nobody though uh
shut your mouth how about that shut your
dumb mouth
california
god damn it i lost my place number 11.
read that read the dumb stat you want to
read
read love read number 11 that you were
going to read read it read it 10 million
baskets no that's not number 11. 10
million that's
what he was dying to get out is
california produces 75
of the crops in the u.s of strawberry
crops 10 million baskets of strawberries
are shipped during daily harvest time in
california florida's second and pr
these stats stink these facts suck uh
perfect temperature all right jesus
christ all right fine
the stats are bad
let's talk candy this is right i don't
even like the way the banana comes
where i want to go
this is where i want to go
your berries your strawberries they're
covered in dirt you got to wash them
they have all pesticides oh my god i
have to wash my fruit but it doesn't
work i'm too fancy to wash my food how
cool i can't do it
how much of a g is the goddamn banana
that it has its own case
no i said it has its own case but then
it also turns into its own points
like a transformer it's like a fruit
transformer god it's the same point just
over and over you want to talk about a g
when i see a strawberry i know what i'm
getting when i get a banana you unpeel
that thing god only knows what's
underneath
magic spoon magic spoon
i got happy that you ever go away on for
the weekend on the road with doing
comedy and maybe you order something off
of amazon or you order something on
online and you get home and you kind of
forgot you ordered it yeah and you get
home and this package is waiting and
you're like oh what is this baby i love
it just happened to be with my magic
spoon i ordered a case of four forgot
all about it i was on the road last week
came back and the guy my guy it was like
he had a package out there so i went and
got the package
four
boxes a magic spoon i've been hitting it
up this week like well i tell you i'm
not just saying this happened to me too
with my magic spoon delivery
got because you get four boxes you know
that's not a that's not a daily or
weekly delivery necessary no no no
nothing right it takes me a minute to
get through it i got to buy i said i
forget what the box looks like it showed
up and i was like what is this yeah this
is exciting magic spoon
is the truly innovative cereal it's a
game changer that lets adults have
cereals that remind them of those sugary
spirit cereals they had back in the day
as kids
let's talk it out right here we spent
time to perfect the crunchy texture
develop an astounding variety of flavors
and they always hit the spot i'm telling
you folks it's true there's a flavor for
everyone zero grams of sugar 13 to 14
grams of protein and only four to five
net grams of carbs in each serving tell
me another bowl of cereal that's doing
that it's low carb keto friendly gluten
free grain free soy free and only 140
calories a serving build your own box
with a huge variety of appealing flavors
which is what i did all of them
by the way yeah they taste like just
like you remember okay
mixed coco and peanut butter for a real
dose of nostalgia which i've already
been doing yeah coco you got your fruity
you got your frosted all those uh peanut
butter the cult phase sweet pastry uh
notes or a smoky syrupy finish you win
no matter what with these oh that's what
cocoa fruity frosting and peanut butter
now blueberry muffin is is one that i'm
having new that's my jump off it's
blueberry yeah that's that's good right
yeah maple waffle and honey nut
indulgent ones move aside cakes and
cookies cereal's got this one covered
and then this i haven't had these so
maybe i'll try to order that next time
cookies and cream and cinnamon roll yeah
go to magicspoon.com taste buds to grab
a custom bundle of cereal and try the
magic for yourself and be sure to use
our promo code taste buds
at checkout to save five dollars off the
order and magic spoon is so confident in
their product
it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason they'll refund your money
absolutely no questions asked remember
get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
taste buds and use code taste buds to
save five dollars off thank you magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode
all right folks
let's talk
what are we talking about stop being
we're talking about upstart babes okay
buds we got to start branding properly
on the show it's going to stop saying
babe on this all right what's up who say
buds buds
buddy babes buddies buds but it can be
hard to see the light at the end of the
tunnel when you have high interest debt
i have been there buddies trust me
everybody's there i swear to you i've
been there and i will be there again i
just was there
and uh interest rates are skyrocketing
yeah i'll probably be revisiting
sometimes it could even be harder to ask
for help that's where upstart comes in
saying goodbye to high interest credit
card debt is one of the first steps
toward financial independence but the
interest month after month can feel like
you're in a never-ending hamster wheel
brutal that's where upstart comes in
guys we've all been there joe has
seemingly out of nowhere we get hit with
unexpected expenses or a bill
and all of a sudden you feel like the
weight of the world is coming down on
you uh and it's normal to not know where
to turn and that is kind of where
upstart comes in upstart powered
personal loans they can help you pay
down high interest debt all online with
simple and easy to understand payment
terms they've helped over 1.8 million
customers find financial freedom whether
it's payoff paying off credit cards or
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses upstart can
help you get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date and i got to
say folks this is a great thing to do i
make jokes about oh i'll be there again
it's in all seriousness once you were
there when you find a way to get help to
get out of it it is a fresh start it
allows you to start over again and you
deserve that you deserve that you
deserve to be let loose in the clutches
of these predatory deals that you sign
when you feel like your back's against
the wall so check out upstart don't wait
any longer
i'm sorry knows you're more than just
your credit score so rather than looking
at your credit score alone upstarts
model considers other factors like your
income employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
you can check your rate within minutes
for loans between 1 000 to 50 000
without impacting your credit score
don't wait check out your rate today at
upstart.com tastebuds that's upstart.com
tastebuds to check your rate today
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you
loan amounts
take it away joe i'm sorry loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com tastebuds when i get a
banana you unpeel that thing god only
knows what's underneath
god only knows that [ __ ] jokes no you
can tell what's inside by what the
outside looks like you know
you could see a banana on the outside
know what it looks like on the inside a
banana is a berry welcome to my world
[ __ ]
this is because botanically a bit a
berry contains seeds inside the flesh
not outside
uh
bro how fun are bananas though they come
with their friends i never got my point
eight of them you could buy a little
mini stack or the huge mother of efforts
you could buy them
with a possibility you rip them away
from your friends you're getting 40
strawberries at a tick it's a pizza
peanut banana broth they're rough riders
you're in the rough ride
banana is famous you want to talk about
famous you want to talk about worldwide
g the chiquita sticker on that banana
with the lady with the fruit bowl over
here that's chiquita baby okay great
chiquita dole it's all banana who do you
got for strawberries doll is not banana
doll is oranges and juice first
pineapples but it's banana let's talk
let's talk chiquita let's talk flavor
people
let me be saving a banana theme song
good
oh you're my man i can't wait to hear
your theme
and then the fans won't complain they
say why does derozan yell all the time
cause he's maddening i'm trying to wind
you up
having a battle let me
pimp don't you dare hit play on that
song
oh you're gonna i'm gonna get this in
your ear like an earworm you're gonna be
singing this all day i'm the chiquita
banana and i'm here to say okay yeah
it's good that's good can i say tropical
my [ __ ] point you [ __ ] god
without a split let's talk strawberry on
ice cream it's so good dude
what a [ __ ] comeback
next to chocolate sauce strawberry sauce
is the second most popular ice cream
sauce
oh get out of here
i want to talk flavors of these fruits
and why strawberries superior i mean for
sure
first tell me that caramel first
strawberry flavored bubble gum
amazing shrub banana flavor gum
disgusting strawberry flavored candy
amazing banana flavored candy disgusting
strawberry
strawberry flavored strawberry flavored
daiquiri amazing banana
daiquiri steak
joe joe everything strawberry could do
banana can do better you're going to
you're going to have the balls to sit
here and tell me you think a banana
strawberry sauce
it's the kids it's the second sausage
caramel joe all right you want me to
prove you wrong right there you can pull
up the dairy queen banana split yeah
pull up the dairy queen bananas put on
put put the most popular
ice cream strawberry cheesecake the
number one cheesecake variation people
prefer it to normal cheesecake yada ya
bird
the three most popular ice cream
toppings
let's see that
there it is wet toppings
wet toppings second picture this one
yeah
yeah but that's just that's just a sun i
want to see what's on that [ __ ]
sunday sunday recipe bro it has
everything on it just go to look at that
i seem to see strawberry topping
caramel and caramel down lower it's just
it's just the way they made the thing
you stupid ass you can't tell me you
can't look me in the face show in all
honesty based on information from 2013
sales data from over 2 400 baskin robins
across the country it seems like most
americans scream the loudest for vanilla
ice cream whipped cream and oreo key
what else do most ice cream eaters crave
here is an infographic you dumb son of a
[ __ ]
top five wet toppings number five
strawberry number four peanut sauce
number three caramel two hot fudge one
real whipped cream
yes you dopey [ __ ] you just proved
yourself wrong you idiot you're such an
idiot good good i'm glad i'm glad you
should be embarrassed you think
strawberry sauce is gonna take caramel
sauce
by the way caramel sauce goes with
banana
caramel sauce doesn't go with strawberry
who gives a [ __ ]
you're an idiot no go back go back to
what you said earlier bananas are
radioactive they contain small amounts
of isotope potassium
potassium
bad potassium no but no it's not banana
is good for potassium it says it's
radioactive right there there's a
version of it that's bad
get the [ __ ] out of here i'm not talking
about a radioactive banana i'm gonna
record
no voice i'm not talking about a
radioactive banana it says
joe bananas are known to bind for
digestion and they're also known for
potassium what is the strawberry known
for disgust
what do you mean
the health benefits of a strawberry
okay fine but i have a key vitamin oh
yeah
i guess we're also taking a vitamin c
everywhere else
these are also packed with fiber
vitamins high levels of antioxidants
sure they are yeah well there you go
there you go what are bananas good for
pimp besides potassium oh also a great
source of potassium and magnesium what
are water let's go banana
bananas are rich
bananas fall into the all right bananas
rich in potassium and fiber low in
sodium oh my god they actually had to
write low in sodium an important
component that's how desperate the
banana is i gotta go it's not very
important
component of heart-healthy diets
okay
hundred hundred milligrams strawberries
are part of every healthy diet okay
every diet every weight loss diet says
if you want to eat fruit eat berries
every single diet
okay scroll 11 evidence-based
evidence-based health benefits of
bananas rich in nutrients improves blood
sugar levels supports digestive health
may aid in weight loss supports heart
health full of antioxidants may help you
feel fuller improve insulin sensitivity
when unripe okay it's a super fruit bro
it's a super fruit south do you see the
key word there may do you see may that
means it's not proof
it said evidence-based another thing is
i want to say this no no no no no you're
not getting off i like when i make i
like when i say the banana has a banana
chocolate and you went banana split
strawberries on ice cream you just
yelled out the fruit and said to dump it
onto the
traditional banana split has strawberry
sauce topping on it idiot [ __ ] [ __ ]
all it does is have it
has by the way split bananas with ice
cream
you want to talk you want to talk
mascots you want to throw that chiquita
broad in my face you want to treat you
would throw a chicken bar on my face
strawberry shortcake strawberry
shortcake and icon plus an icon for
young girls strawberry
strawberry shortcake is is consumer
based that's a character
famous cartoon character pita banana is
the actual product bro never saw never
saw a banana
lady doll for the kids hey mommy can i
have a miss banana for christmas because
it doesn't exist it's crazy
[Music]
now this floozy's walking around
slaunder
wears this is what a banana's got to
sink to to sell itself it's got to [ __ ]
it up around around a bunch of sailors
are we going to get are we not going to
be able to play this because of the
i know but i don't want to get i don't
want to have the finish where you're
looking means are right for cooking
i don't remember this song no no oh it i
mean you don't remember it's only iconic
i don't remember it do you remember the
strawberry shortcut cake theme that's
iconic to a lot of people
remember you can't compare strawberry
shortcake to the chicken wait till you
lose this battle
this is the mascot of the banana what
about whatever happened ice cream pie
we're at 24 minutes i feel like i've
been screaming for an hour over here
because you know why we didn't start
with anything we went right into this
all right fair enough
you want to take a timeout
no well you know what's so great you
ever look up at a banana tree even
though it's not a tree and just you've
never in your life seen a banana tree
why are you talking like staten island
is riddled with banana trees
did you ever look i've been overseas
i've been in hawaii please back me up on
this did you ever look up a bit of
banana tree he makes it sound like he's
talking about a christmas tree he makes
it sound like this is a common occasion
in my life a hundred times what are you
talking about okay what are you talking
about i'm not on staten island okay not
in new york just so no i've never seen a
banana run on vacation or to a tropical
area yeah i'm sorry if i could only
afford vacations inside the country
i've never been to uh israel or wherever
you saw your bananas
where are the bananas where did you see
them what said israel where did you see
it
you were grown in the u.s
colder parts of alaska midwest the north
hawaii yes that's where i saw him hawaii
tell me hawaii and florida all right so
tell me about both in the contingent
united states you dopey [ __ ]
well florida doesn't i mean hawaii
doesn't count okay fine
go ahead did i ever look up at a banana
tree and what it's it's just cool dude
you ever seen someone scale a banana
tree ah it's fun i've seen video okay
let me ask you ever see the first day of
the the warm weather starting and you
see a blooming strawberry bush you can
yeah that's strawberry that's happening
in your life 100
we had a bush on our property yeah all
right we had a bush on our property my
dad my daddy grew strawberries
strawberries he had a garden
he had a garden why do you not speak to
the fact that the the banana i i want to
go back to this because i think it is
you you made me push past it and i think
it's amazing the banana is a fruit like
an orange
that has its own
coat it has its own shell its own
protective covering you don't have to
wash a banana before you eat it you
could pick a banana right out of a tree
and be throwing that banana in your
mouth and within why do you think this
is a bonus i also you think you can't
pluck a strawberry off a bush and just
eat it yeah you might have some
pesticides in dirt and [ __ ] on there
naturally grown area okay right also you
don't love peeling a banana and then
having the peel itself be the holder
that protects your hands as opposed to
what the messiness of holding a
strawberry strawberry oh god don't get
strawberry juice on your shirt that'll
stain that'll say who's getting
strawberry juice put the whole
strawberry in your mouth you psycho
savage
oh you're just you're popping large
strawberries in your mouth at one time
don't spill it on your shirt and then
you gotta you you know you do you have
to pick up the the the the least part on
the front and you have to get out no you
pluck the leaves off before you eat then
you eat that little hard stem at the top
there's no stem at the top if you pluck
the leaves off properly you don't know
how to eat a strawberry strawberry juice
gets on you you're going to have to get
it why are the strawberries come to the
united states i'll tell you what doesn't
stain banana the banana has never
stained anything because it's a
flavorless mush wow except it's not and
by the way banana flavored candy is the
most disgusting of all your bananas your
most popular now and later flavors oh i
can't wait yeah yeah yeah i'm sure
banana is going to be way up that list
let's get to it baby
no no i think scroll up a little
look we're all adults here and i know
some of us choose nicotine to relax to
focus or just unwind after a long day
lucy is a modern oral nicotine company
that makes nicotine gum lozenges and
pouches for adults who are looking for
the best most responsible way to consume
their nicotine it's a new year why not
start it out by switching to a new
nicotine product that you can feel good
about i used lucy and i found that it
helped greatly in all the ways that they
say it does trust me on that if you're
using if you enjoy using nicotine you
should definitely check out lucy's
products at lucy.co that's lucy.co and
use promo code tastebuds at checkout
also i have to read this disclaimer
warning this product contains nicotine
nicotine is an addictive chemical
remember if you're interested in a
better way to use nicotine visit lucy.co
and be sure to use promo code
slot omaniah
i love when you sing thank you
guys are you bored because i'm
i am i need some excitement you have
that go-to thing that's like taking
every time that you can't wait to do
that's fun that you like look forward to
doing because if you don't you should
try a slotted maniac the world's number
one free slots game a hefty dose of fun
in your day whenever you need it life's
too short for a day without fun get a
thrill wherever you need it with
slaughter maniacs
170
free to play slot games huge jackpots
interactive community
and a million free coins that's a
perfect escape for for for my day for my
daily routine is it i think it's going
to be a perfect escape from years there
was a
game on nintendo that used to be called
vegas dreams oh i remember and it it was
the first game to like become really fun
for me as far as like the whole like
little casino and slot world because
they would put a story line to it yeah
and you could actually like you know and
i i remember being it was so fun and i
haven't really felt that way about like
a like a like a slot game or anything
like that until this one it's also like
it's colorful it's fun like you know
what you know like it's just fun to play
like the graphics the music it's just
it's just cool and i do it on on the
plane it helps my plane rides go by so
much faster i like what they're doing
you're going to get a rush when you win
a big jackpot trust me on that that's a
lot of little mini games and stuff and
you're giving yourself a little me time
to relax each day with a fun mix of
casino gaming and casual gaming anytime
you want it babe when you hit a jackpot
i don't care if it's
free on slaughter mania or real you you
feel the rush when you hit that jacket
jackpot again you're getting one million
free coins when you download slaughter
mania to kickstart the fun
uh there is nothing more exhilarating
than huge jackpots special prizes and a
free corn coin rewards every day the
other thing too is you can interact with
fellow players and you can form these
like cooperative uh like like clan like
they call them slaughter clans
like so it's like it's like you if you
have if you play and i play and we could
take our group text to the slottomania i
got you and do like a little thing by
the way this is the thrill of vegas in
the palm of your hand and we don't need
to tell you all the bad parts about
vegas
just take the good stuff with you in
your pocket and have some fun
slot
when your day is feeling stale just ask
what will today spin if you're 21 or
older you can get you can join millions
of players around the world you download
slot oh mania the number one free
slots game on the app store or google
play store and get over a million free
coins that's slotto mania on the app
store or the google play store for 1
million free coins
folks just to keep in mind this is not a
cash out kind of thing this is all free
it's a free way to play and have fun
that's all it is all right yes so just
enjoy yourself with this free
thing
yeah but ranked is gonna be someone's
opinion it doesn't matter let's get
something all right you know what i mean
it's better than nothing top selling
because they all sell together
yeah that's tough
i i i'll tell you he gave me banana now
and later to throw him at you i actually
i love bananas
the worst of the runs i love banana oh
my god runs i have the i have runs in
the front
in the candy machine go get him bananas
maybe orange go get some let's do it
right now let me get some yeah go get
some here's some strawberry stuff
late 1700s the garden strawberries made
their way back to the americas so we
were here first
1825 strawberry production was well
established in the united states we beat
you there one of the first popular
cultivators was hovi introduced in 1838
by charles hovey a fruit grower plant
breeder and writer from massachusetts
pimp you're going to taste one of these
in the taste test
we'll do a strawberry versus a banana
oh god banana stinks
do you like banana flavored candy pimp i
just had banana with spinach smoothie
but that's different okay do you banana
with spinach oh my god i'll barf
[Laughter]
banana swedish because banana does that
bro
yeah i'm sure i'm sure it blended
seamlessly with the spinach
you want anything else no no i'm good i
just want to so i'll do a banana and a
strawberry
which one are you doing first is the
question
i'll go banana first
i'm going to do banana first
you're talking to mike so
it's already gross
it's a homely flavor i would describe it
as
strawberry it's an ugly flavor what you
should do about nothing
it
it doesn't like any other
berry flavored something like it just it
just tastes like it doesn't taste like
real strawberry just tastes like oh i
got news for you bananas don't taste
like real bananas this is the most fun
shape the strawberry is in a banana the
banana is disgusting i already did it
i'm gonna go strawberry now
banana's insulate i it's not
it's not even broken yet it only broke
in half and i'm tasting like what real
banana tastes like in my mouth it tastes
nothing like real banana
it tastes nothing like romano and let's
not discount and you use so much
real banana and that could be
influencing the flavor in your mouth
it's not influencing the flavor of my
mouth you idiot oh my god listen to me
strawberry i'm right back as a kid it
tastes like candy it's fun i'm having a
good time
[Laughter]
honestly swear to god i wouldn't even
banana blows strawberry away and runs it
blows it away again
you agree yeah i like banana better than
strawberry in runs at least it is
so much better i'm i got them both now
going here's like the second time i bite
open get that tartness in the strawberry
this is the second time i've ever had
once out of that thing ever
oh the middle of the banana
the banana is good
sal look at this
fan comment which one
given
gwen stefani oh my orange is really
gwen stefani
uh
ha ha ha
i love you
it's sam loop is that the name gwen
stefani didn't sing a song about
strawberries now did she
the [ __ ] is bananas bro i don't know
if you're going to come at me with an
argument that contains gwen stefani dude
herbie went bananas herbie didn't go
strawberries
why are they even hurting
bananas
why are they even called something's
bananas it's a good thing oh dude oh my
gosh
did you see the concert it was bananas
did you see the game i said yes bro it
was a banana
did you catch the game last night it was
strawberries bro yeah now the third time
you've made the joke didn't land the
first two times
the strawberry was better once it opened
see yeah you see
thank you can we scroll through some
phones here pimp also
our chimp eating the bananas you're
talking just keep talking let me start
chipping the banana what's better than
that give me your strawberry equivalent
of a chimp eating a banana do you know
that i have a statue from my parents
home when i was little of
a chimpanzee eating a banana that i
saved to this day did you know nobody
gives a [ __ ] who cares what do you mean
that's right he was edited
to my house today to talk about this
stuff that's why people listen for two
years because they give a [ __ ] what are
you doing about
oh my god these some of these
that's very funny love a good banana
that could be our winner that's very
funny
uh if you choose dick-shaped food over
heart-shaped food i worry about you
peel and slice a banana freeze it put
the frozen bananas in food processor all
right let's stop
uh we'd be remiss if we didn't give a
shout out to the versatility of the
banana as an ingredient
muffins sugar strawberry muffins
banana bread
banana bread psycho banana bread banana
bread jesus christ oh you guys i'm gonna
have a stroke you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna get demolished strawberry
and banana both can top things but
banana i'm trying to read a thing in
your favor and you can't stop yeah
because you can't find one in your favor
good go
did you hear what i just said i'm trying
to rethink your faith
yourself
gotta feed you like a child you're both
in some chocolate and i'm in
i can't do banana growing up i take
medicine on the regular and it's
smelling tastes like bananas that's a
great point so many kids medicines smell
like banana
strawberry or sweetened
that's not a great point what are you
talking about bananas bananas taste like
paste and it's let's not even discuss
how these flavors are used in other
things candy ice cream etc because it
would be unfair to the banana thank you
johnny cash 718. good good strawberries
are unbeatable even thanos bows down and
takes the l uh sorry babe i only eat
bananas
and like muffins i like strawberry
anything i forgot about banana bread i
totally forgot and i forgot about
bananas in muffins which is similar i
forgot about strawberry cake strawberry
strawberries not in muffins
strawberry muffin come on joe don't just
start adding strawberry to items
strawberry cake is a hundred percent a
thing and it's awesome strawberry cake
yes yes strawberry sure i'm talking
about the strawberry muffin when was the
last time you like uh let me get the
strawberry muffin and please see if
strawberry muffins exist you could put
anything into a muffin joe but it's not
a it's not a regular muffin remember
when you said that banana cream pie was
was a commonplace i can't tell you the
last time i've seen one
strawberry muffins 100 recipes here for
strawberry muffins nah strawberry
weren't you the one saying you love
banana pancakes was that you no okay was
it joe i like bananas in their
natural form
i do not like banana flavored anything
ever
and i like bananas and ice cream
anything else i don't want them near me
that's the truth you don't do banana in
the cereal
hell yeah
corn flakes rice krispies cheerios i
sliced that banana and you want to get
into seriously i'm a kid when you get
cheerios let's talk about how did you
put your strawberry in series let's talk
about how many cereals come with
freeze-dried strawberries in them
already oh that's a good that's that's
yeah that's good freeze-dried great okay
they come up they tried everything they
have freeze-dried blueberries they have
freeze-dried strawberry is the top
contender with banana in the cereal
department is fruit you put in cereal
but bananas number one well what's that
oh jelly strawberry jelly strawberry jam
strawberry marmalade
on your toast ain't making a banana
jelly oh peanut butter banana sandwich
on my toast how about that ghost scrub
that was his favorite food peanut butter
and strawberry jelly sandwich which are
you choosing the one with the bananas or
the one with the strawberry i want my
jelly grape bud strawberry
strawberry jelly can go scratch i never
like a strawberry jelly strawberry jelly
you put a grape jelly in the strawberry
jelly in front of you and i asked you to
make 100 sandwiches you're making 100
jelly and peanut butter toast grapefruit
toast more than anything else strawberry
jelly on toast the butter is amazing if
you had strawberry jelly on an it's uh
if you were gonna make it a peanut
butter and jelly would you use grape
jelly or something
now i've evolved onto toast i'm talking
about toast strawberry jam on an english
muffin with butter is one of the most
amazing things in the morning and you
goddamn no it is grape jelly is first
though you know that no not on on an
english muffin yeah no on a peanut
butter and jelly yes on an english
muffin no and you know that peanut
butter and banana sandwich
oh how about pop tarts there's no banana
flavored pop tart that's a great
argument that's you got me you just
swung the whole thing there you just
swung the whole thing that pop banana
doesn't make an artificial butter banana
flavored cookies are there with banana
filling are you nuts
are you nuts tell me one
joe bananas in everything bread and
everything all right let's go back up
there's nothing that banana can't do
nothing
no no like a brand chocolate chip banana
brand name yeah yeah all right so you
pull up banana cookies but he wants to
say the bananas with strawberry muffins
you didn't want to hear it so now i'm
playing by your rules let's see how you
bring out mcdonald's let's try to bring
up mcdonald's before we get out of here
well uh a strawberry flurry is wonderful
and also there are three milkshake
flavors at mcdonald's chocolate vanilla
and strawberry not banana not banana son
i think you're gonna lose bro let's go
back to the phones pimp but
wait wait wait did you not want to read
this hold on a second now what fresh
fruit do americans eat the most
americans seem to agree as fruit sales
make up 47 of all produce per store
weekly dollars
according to produce marketing
association bananas rain surprises
consumers also eat plenty of apples
grape strawberries unfair statistic it's
a year-round fruit versus a seasonal
fruit that is completely unfair and the
fact that my fruit pops up
in second place with its limited run
every year no how about you're in
trouble before said that strawberries
are grown in all 50 states while bananas
are grown in hawaii and florida so
seasonal doesn't matter it doesn't
matter you you produce them all over the
our great land doesn't matter it's a
seasonal fruit
all right pimp strawberries all day
however bananas are more fun to eat
bananas are our better foundation we
talked about the fact that the product
looks like a penis like smoothies and
healthy recipes but they're all on their
own they can't compete with strawberries
thank you
fredo asked for a banana daiquiri i'm
all set on this one
give the win to emmett that's so funny
follow at irish chick a go kid
chicago
what time is it right now what where are
we at
uh 42 minutes okay we could do that you
got anything to say i i'm gonna say that
uh
i'm i feel very confident that i'm gonna
win this i'll say this in closing yeah
i've tried several runs now yeah lime is
king
lime's the worst one so everyone agree
with that and now everyone now you know
where his palette lies lime is the worst
candy of all candies in every and
everything okay and
lime is no good in in in in lollipops
lime is no good in s
lime is very good
no one likes lime all right pimp
mime should've never got into candy all
right pimp you guys have any plugs
yes
joederosainfo.com all my dates coming up
uh san francisco fairfield connecticut
atlantic city
san diego
l.a a lot of stuff coming up go to
joedan joederosa info.com for tickets
and info
for all shows and then also joey rose's
as always new york city
on the lower east side go to joey rose's
nyc for all information there please
come see us all right so before we get
to this thing let me just tell you uh i
have six dates coming up in july and
that's all i'm going to plug and i'm
going to give away free bananas at all
of them it is las vegas phoenix and
boulder colorado july 15 16 and 17 and
then we have portland seattle and
vancouver july
2021 and 22. they're all on sale right
now at savile county comedy.com i won't
be out there to that for a while guys so
get your tickets now i will give free
bananas i will bring free bananas i'm
gonna do it and then buy bushels of
bananas and hand them out and then we're
gonna make a video and i'm gonna
text it to you i'm gonna ride
humble pie here we go
oh yes
take that and eat it in your own [ __ ]
strawberry sixty four point three
percent it's wild dude to the banana at
35.7 percent wild
that's wild
oh my god you got to be kidding me man i
still love you i love you too
oh i'm let down i'm let down that might
have been the biggest upset i've ever
recognized
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right taste buds man
yeah they come